I don't think there's a more iconic
figure in Greek mythology than Medusa
and in most cases it's not because of
her story or her character but because
of her appearance if you ask someone who
knows next to nothing about mythology
who Medusa is it's likely they'll tell
you it's that snake haired woman who can
turn people into stone the most viewed
video on this channel is the story of
Medusa as told by the Roman poet Ovid
looking back now it's not a video I'm
particularly pleased with because it
doesn't really tell the whole story and
it also gives the wrong impression to
those not willing to look any deeper so
today I'll combine everything I've
discussed in the past regarding Medusa
hopefully into one coherent video as we
take a look at the many faces behind
Greek mythology's most iconic monster
[Music]
[Music]
before we begin you need to forget
everything you think you know Medusa was
not a woman transformed into a Gorgon at
least not to begin with what's important
to note is that the Gorgon has appeared
all throughout Greek mythology
potentially stretching as far back as
6,000 BC
so their appearance and meaning has gone
through several changes the first
mention of snake head women comes from
the Erinyes or the Furies these three
were in charge of punishing men who had
committed the unspeakable crimes on
earth they were depicted as ugly winged
the women who had poisonous serpents
entwined around their arms their waist
and more importantly their hair the
renews may not have been considered
Gorgon but they were very similar in
terms of appearance to the very first
Gorgon the very first Gorgon is referred
to as the elder Gorgon who by some was
considered Medusa's father whilst others
equated this image to another figure
known as Gorgo the daughter of the Titan
the Helios just by looking at Gorgo it
is pretty hard to tell if it's a male or
a female
these early depictions aren't seductive
women with snake hair they had beards
tasks and curly hair which may have been
where the transition into snakes started
from
Gorgo would eventually be killed by Zeus
during the Titanomachy
at this point in time the Gorgons had no
real paribus and medusa certainly wasn't
mentioned by name these bearded women
continued appearing until they were
established as the protectors of
Oracle's their appearance slightly
changed however they now had scales for
skin sharp claws wings and locks of hair
entwined with snakes a mix between the
arenas and a harpy we then begin to hear
about the Gorgons and literature around
the 8th century BC with Homer's Iliad
here Homer refers to the aegis which was
a shield commonly associated with Zeus
and Athena in
crusted of the head of a Gorgon the
protective figure of the auricles now
also featured in myths around Zeus and
Athena it's also not that strange for
many cultures to ward off evil of
something even more terrifying before
Homer's Iliad that all we had recorded
about Gorgons came from pottery and
sculptures so the eighth century BC
onwards marks when the Gorgons began to
develop as characters and in terms of
story in homers next piece the Odyssey
the Gorgon is mentioned once again but
this time as an awful monster by the way
it's written it appears Homer believed
there was only one Gorgon the 7th
century BC is where the story starts to
become more familiar in his Theogony
Hesiod states that there are three
Gorgons the daughters of the primordial
sea deities Seto and four seas this is
also one of the first times they're
mentioned by name steno the mighty
uhreally of the wide sea and medusa the
queen of these three sisters Medusa is
the only one described as mortal but
it's unclear if she was mortal as in she
looked different from her sisters or
mortal as in she would age sculptures
and vases of this time would suggest all
three were seen having a monstrous form
in 490 BC the poet pindarus referred to
medusa as fair-cheeked Medusa several
hundred years on from homer and hesiod
'he's work medusa unlike her sisters
began to be shown as beautiful as well
as terrifying as more poets mentioned
medusa and the Gorgons they were
established as not only having serpents
for hair but also a stare that could
turn anyone into stone
now I'm sure what most people have been
waiting for is the story that involves
Medusa Poseidon and Athena because
that's the most dramatized version
Hesiod does briefly mentioned some kind
of seduction between Poseidon and Medusa
when he says they laid together in a
field of spring flowers but most of the
time this is pretty much just ignored
when overed published his metamorphosis
in the 8th century AD he spoke about
over 200 different myths and stories one
of the most popular of course being the
story of Medusa there are 3 things that
are important to note about Ovid 1 many
of these stories are much more
dramatized than the poets and historians
who came before him - he wasn't the gods
biggest fan and so whenever he had the
chance to paint them in a negative light
he took it and three he was Roman this
is important because the Romans did view
some gods in a different light - the
Greeks
Athena and Ares been good examples
unlike those who came before him over it
was one of the first to describe Medusa
as completely human a young maiden
without the physical traits of her
sisters in this interpretation Poseidon
attempts to seduce Medusa and when she
rejects his advances she flees into one
of Athena's temples he follows her
inside and then has his way with her
anyway which is probably the best way I
can describe it without being
demonetised Athena see in these events
unfold was angered that her temple had
been defiled in this manner
she then punished Medusa by transforming
her into a snake head monster any man
who looked at her from that day on would
be turned into stone and if that wasn't
enough she was then sent into exile
the next time she appears as in the
story of Perseus who needed to retrieve
her head in order to defeat the sea
monster Cetus with help from the gods
Perseus decapitate smih deucey and from
her neck sprung her to children the
winged steed Pegasus and the golden
giant cry saw Athena's curse prevented
her from having these children and the
father was of course Poseidon the main
issue of OVAs version is it's the only
one that claims of this interaction
between Medusa and person
it also paints Athena in a light that we
never see from any other Greek poet
Poseidon or Neptune's actions are not
out of the norm for him but here there
are mentions of Athena being jealous of
Medusa's beauty as well as being Petty
and fairly irrational which is something
we see again in Ovid story involving
Athena and Arachne it's pretty clear
over doesn't like Athena or in this case
Minerva which does make sense
considering the Romans valued Mars or
Ares over Minerva and Athena everything
prior to Ovid story points towards
Athena being one of if not the most
level-headed rational and respected
deities in the Greek pantheon which
honestly at times isn't very difficult
but she still was I guess you could say
as somewhat of a retaliation to Ovid
story the Greeks adapted the ending
athena instead transformers Medusa into
a Gorgon as a way of protecting herself
she couldn't continuously watch over her
so as a Gorgon no man could ever harm
her again there are some stories from
Greek sources where Athena did punish
Medusa in one of these Medusa compared
her beauty to the gods and we all know
how hubris goes in this case the
transformation was to teach her a lesson
if you're going to disrespect others
based on your own beauty especially the
gods they can easily take it away
you also have variations of this story
where Medusa slept with Poseidon in
Athena's temple for her own personal
gain so again the punishment here makes
more sense it's no coincidence that the
original Medusa video blew up shortly
after high-profile cases of sexual
assault were thrust into the mainstream
media I honestly don't know if people
genuinely believed Medusa's case was
more than a fictional story or whether
the idea of a woman being sexually
assaulted and then blamed is something
that resonated all those who had been
through a similar experience either way
I'm not here to tell you that you're
wrong
if Ovid version is the story that you
most relate to but if the only thing you
take away is that Medusa was a victim
treated unfairly then you miss out on so
much if you go by Ovid version then even
in her own story Medusa has
no importance there's nothing really
positive to take away from this story
and that does belittle what she in the
gorgon have symbolized throughout
history the Gorgon born Medusa we
mentioned earlier was a symbol of
protection her face appeared on amulets
known as the gorgonian which kept away
evil spirits in later years her face was
even painted on the front of women's
shelters to let them know these were
places where they could feel safe even
in death her head was used by Perseus to
defeat Cetus and save Andromeda after
Medusa's death
Athena took her head and placed it on
the ages the ultimate sign of protection
and power the reason I wanted to title
this video within many phases of Medusa
is not only because her change in
appearance literally means she has many
different faces but because there are
many different science to her she isn't
just a victim she's a monster a villain
a maiden a mother a symbol of protection
and a source of hope all rolled into one
there aren't many characters in Greek
mythology that can be interpreted in so
many different ways and elicits so many
different emotions and none of them are
wrong it just comes down to which one
you prefer and what you choose to take
from it if you have enjoyed the opening
artwork and animation for this video
they were created by the very talented
mando Teresa if you would like to see
the process behind creating these Gorgon
paintings I'll leave a link to her video
and YouTube channel along with her other
socials so you guys can head over there
and show her the appreciation she
deserves
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
you
you